antwerp in belgium one of europe's crime
hotspots
each year superintendent luke mass and
his team seize dozens of powerful sedans
from criminals
unfortunately all too often criminals
are slipping through the net
to complicate matters yet more for the
police and judicial authorities
criminals can easily cross national
borders
to combat this phenomenon and strengthen
cooperation between the different eu
member states meps in the plenary want
to create an operational anti-mafia
network
police and justices again on a yearly
basis on a global scale criminals
launder around 1500 billion euros right
under the nose of the states
meps have set tackling money laundering
as one of their top priorities to reach
the same they propose the
standardization of criminal law we need
to close the the loopholes we need to
make sure that we know who are the
beneficiary owners of companies so that
we so that you cannot hide
shady deals or tax evasion behind shell
companies we need to increase the level
of due diligence by banks so that banks
make sure that the assets that the
assets that are deposited are not from
also dubious sources meps are also
striving to enhance the credibility of
criminal justice
sentences should be proportional to the
sum of money laundered for example
now all that remains is to convince the
member states of the merits of their
recommendations and get them on board